what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into flash
rebirth for the grips of strength which
is like the strength force now again for
those of you guys who are just now
catching up with the flash mythos what
we ended up having during the events of
dark nights metal and and going into
like Justice League no justice and all
those different things was that because
of dark nights metal this source wall
had been cracked and because a source
wall had been cracked there's been like
a lot of implications that have been
spreading across the entirety of the DC
universe and one of them with regards to
the flash was the revelation of like
four new forces right you always had the
Speed Force maybe was three new forces
always to the Speed Force any other sage
force to strength force and so on it
allows Joshua Williamson to actually
expand a lot on the flash mythos which
if I'm being honest and I know flash
fans may be a little irritated by this
but I think it's something that's much
much needed because at the end of the
day all the flash stories ever really
come down to is just run faster and I
guess it makes sense I mean Superman
stories are just punch harder and Batman
stories are just you know bat harder I
guess like whatever the case is like
like it's basically just like do more of
what you do and and that's your story ah
the flash runs so I mean what is what is
gonna do is you're just gonna like learn
to fly but at any event with what's been
going on so far Barry goes to the House
of Heroes and hits up all the versions
of the flash across the multiverse now
this is kind of a cool thing because you
get to see like the zoo crew and stuff
like that you know the the land where
all the all the superheroes are
basically animals are Catholic here
Catholic carrot got men you get man you
guys know I love Captain met Captain
carrot Kevin carrots the super bunny
I love Captain kit I love Captain carrot
but this is not something that we see
very often now for those of you guys who
were unfamiliar with this in DC
originally there was no real map of the
multiverse and in the aftermath of Final
Crisis Grant Morrison started working on
one the problem was that within two
years of Final Crisis DC rebooted so
they told Grant Morrison just roll it
over into the new 52 and just say this
is the map the the map of the multiverse
in new 52 but nonetheless what you have
at like the center of all this is the
House of Heroes as basically we're like
like all the various superheroes from
across the multiverse can meet so like
the multiversal Justice League and like
as you see here the different flashes of
the multiverse a different Superman the
different Wonder Woman you have this
whole house of Heroes place where people
can meet up and it's kind of a it's a
joint meeting point a joint meeting
place and so very highly calls everybody
and says look here's what's been going
on on my world
have you guys seen anything along the
same lines because remember the the
Speed Force doesn't permeate a universe
it permeates the multiverse and so every
speedster across the in every single
universe could potentially experience
thing like this the issue is that all of
them say no now one thing to bear in
mind here I don't know this is something
that Williamson is toying with or
something that is just not worrying
about the form and function of the
multiverse and DC Comics despite how
it's drawn by Grant Morrison has always
been like an upside down pyramid and the
first earth in the upside-down pyramid
is the main DC Universe earth earth
prime that's where all these stories
that are being written right now in DC
rebirth that's where they all take place
and so it could very well be that if
there is a fracture in the source wall
and the various forces are leaking out
they started as Prime and then we'll
eventually resonate their way out into
the other earth that's entirely possible
but the fact remains because none of
them were able to give him any real
definitive answers here what we end up
doing is basically picking up with like
trickster trickster is one of these guys
who was who was who was serving time in
iron Heights and who's basically going
to work against like wardens wolf and
warden wolf was this guy who's he's the
guy running the whole iron Heights
penitentiary but he's been pretty shady
and he's actually been experimenting on
and torturing a lot of the criminals
that are there but they can't just walk
in and arrest warden wolf because
there's no evidence that any of its gone
on what they need is for Trixie to go in
and then to literally set up evidence to
show evidence this is what's going on
and then essentially build a case for
the the central city police department
the problem is that in the middle of all
that basically like these almost
parademon guys literally show up out of
nowhere you know these these pair of
angels as they're called and literally
just like started to start like try
carry off tricksters which is kind of
nuts because we're Barry Allen shows up
you know and he literally chases him off
and manages to defeat a handful of them
we also end up getting commander cold
now again commander cold is part of the
Rogues that were sent to the modern day
in order to apprehend everything the
problem is that he's been stuck here
this entire time he can't get back home
and so he's basically done working
alongside Barry but it's not really that
the closest relationship with them
because commander cold is pretty
hardcore I mean no pun intended
he's pretty cold-blooded in the sense
that like he literally freezes one of
the para angels and then is just gonna
let him fall to their death now he ends
up revealing to Barry no it's not a
great big huge deal you know as soon as
I let off the trigger they would they
would fall out anyway it was a way to
incapacitate them but Barry didn't
noticed and so in the middle of all this
trickster basically races off only for
the ground to open up underneath him
like like you know drag me to hell
tricksters basically drugged down below
ground and like we have no idea what
happened so he just kind of sucked down
there and then just vanishes and then
from there we end up picking up with
like Barry and iris now the conversation
between Barry and iris is very very
interesting here because remember all of
her memories are starting to come back
keep in mind dr. Manhattan took 10 years
of
he's from everyone's life and they've
all been gone it's only just now that
she's getting back memories of the fact
that she was married to Barry have the
two of them had a life together this is
something that she never knew about
before because those memories were gone
but it's one thing that she's keeping
hidden from Barry which is not very
characteristic of iris historically
speaking when you look at her character
in DC comics going all the way back to
the day and even ended back with like
eobard thawne killed her and all those
crazy things were going on in the 70s
for the most part you didn't really see
iris holding a lot of things away from
Barry no a lot of that was because of
the perpetuation of like the platonic
household I'm sorry the the the nuclear
family the idea of like a husband a wife
a son and a daughter and like nobody
really keeps things from each other
anymore
I mean 2018 everybody hides and lies
like each other so in that scenario like
we're kind of used to it now but that's
not really the way it should be when it
comes to iris and Barry so it is a
little strange there but irises
responses you have to learn to work with
commander colt he's not captain cold
he's not Leonard snart so you don't have
to worry about him being like the guy
that you're familiar with give the guy a
chance learn about it because you may
end up finding out he's nothing like
like snart you don't know anything about
him so you can't really make judgment
calls on him and it's kind of cool
because when Barry tracks down a
basically you know ends up getting a
call from commander colt when he is up
getting to his location
suddenly trickster emerges from the
ground looking like a combination of the
Incredible Hulk and Ben Grimm to think
because what's happened here is he's
imbued with a strength force now and
that's why it's kind of cool here this
is a way for Williamston to kind of toy
with the idea and to see how the fan
base responds to it and then if they
like it either keep it going exactly the
way it is maybe even modify it a little
bit because when we're talking about
these forces like like the the Speed
Force it's pretty much infinite for the
most part I mean you know it's relative
to like what a person's body can handle
but like if you were to have someone
like Darkseid for example get ahold of
the Speed Force I'd say he'd be able to
withstand a lot of the rigors you know
pushing the Speed Force to the limit as
opposed to like bury or Wally because
they still have a physical body you
could kill Barry Allen with a bullet so
he's not like indestructible you know
it's just one of those things where
you'd have to shoot him so he doesn't
know who's coming otherwise he just ran
out of the way or you'd hear like the
gunfire he would hear that the sound of
the gun before the bullet ever reached
him it must be nice to be a flash okay
let me ask you guys this question real
quick kind of a sidetrack here if you
could have any superhuman power what
would it be like I'm kind of curious to
see what your also what your all stake
is on this but with them shaking down
trickster it's almost like this this
insurmountable force because it's just
like raw relentless
strength is all this is running through
and ripping everything to pieces and so
were they they they try to faceoff they
try to stop them as best they can
there's not a whole lot they can do but
Barry actually vibrates through the hand
of trickster which releases them but in
turn tricksters body starts to react to
everything that's going on almost as if
it throws his atoms into a state of like
disarray and so what what seems to be
going on is like he's literally losing
his connection to the strength force
like Barry who disrupted it and in doing
so like the strength force begins to
dissipate and he begins to leave and so
what they end up doing is they end up
taking trickster doc to iron Heights
they have them jump into a tube they
have variable output and you know they
put Mary in the tube is as well and then
they start the process of like having
them punched through and seeing if like
this energy can be transferred if it can
be deviated in some form or fashion the
problem with this is that because the
strength force is such an extreme amount
of energy that's confined within the
body of trickster and it's basically
rejecting him it's turning his body into
a physical bomb he'll detonate with this
massive amount of energy because that's
one of the things to bear in mind when
it comes to things like these forces
sage for strength for Speed Force
they're basically energy and so because
of this tricksters body literally just
starts to explode Barry Allen races into
the way and when that happens all the
strength force is absorbed directly into
Barry and he ends up looking like The
Incredible Hulk like the flash becomes a
Hulk basically it's really what this is
and it's kind of cool he doesn't lose
his mind right it's not like he turns it
like a savage Hulk or anything like that
instead it's a matter of one keeping
everybody from killing trickster and
then to trying to figure out how
tricksters powers work so we can
understand how his powers work and see
if there's a way to control it but it's
the one thing that no one's given tricks
or an opportunity to find out is how his
powers work and so because of the fact
that Barry thinks his SuperSpeed he's
able to analyze his powers of super
speed and that's when he begins to
realize this strength force is not just
brutal strength instead is really
manipulating gravity it's almost like he
becomes kind of like graviton and Hulk
from marvel at the same time he's just
kind of manipulating the fundamental
forces of gravity and increasing his own
strength or decreasing his own strength
in the process that the strength force
has to be let out that if a person keeps
it totally contained then that's what
it'll begin to override them that's what
it'll begin to reject them and that's
when they'll become the most dangerous
and so Barry's responses will then use
the strength force as an external as an
external source that way you have all
this energy that pumps into you
constantly because remember the Speed
Force constantly pumps into you the
strength forth is the exact same way
it's like draining a water-cooled system
in a PC and so when it when it comes to
this Barry starts to basically channel
this energy outward you
literally manipulating gravity and in
doing so begins to return to a state of
normalcy and so it's kind of cool
because basically it allows them to
understand the fundamental principles of
the power now this is not Joshua
Williamson saying this is the end-all
be-all of the strength force this is
just very understanding how the strength
force works there's probably a lot of
other things that he can understand
Danny and Barry even references that he
says when he first became the flash all
he knew he could do was run but the more
time he became the flash the more he
began to realize that he can face
through solid objects past through
dimensional barriers all kinds of crazy
stuff that a flash can achieve and
that's just the tip of the iceberg and
so when he faces off against trickster
he starts kind of pulling all these
little stops out he basically like lists
Rictor is a trickster in the air he
dragged him to him just small little
things like that and it's cool to see
because as they're fighting each other
this strength for power really begins to
kind of almost evaporate from Barry and
and jump right back into trickster again
and then leave trickster and then seek
out seek out a different host somewhere
else and that's when Barry begins to
realize that much like the Speed Force
the strength force doesn't does itself
appear to be something akin to sent him
and is always seeking out a new house
trickster was never a viable host it was
a temporary host until the strength
force could find somebody else and when
trickster basically ran its course then
you ended up having the strength force
which left him and now it's going to
seek someone new and so it's a way for
Joshua Williamson to invoke like new
villains into the flash mythos and so
where you end up having tricks you're
holding up this building that's
literally at hub of all the Rogues is
about to collapse and very races and you
know and then rescues them it all
collapses on trickster and that really
seems to be the end of him it's all said
and done and so from there you end up
switching over to trickster himself
who's basically in a weird repository
building like a library or something
along those lines and as he's kind of
musing to himself over the belief that
he was dead and that he had as this
brief moment of famous brief brief
moment of like respect among the Rogues
which is now basically gone he's reached
out a lending hand by a guy who says I'm
the one who sent the hairy Angels after
you if you would simply just done what I
told you you would have come here and we
would have found a way to destroy the
flash together and that's when you end
up finding out the person who is
reaching out to trickster is the
original trickster james jesse and this
is a weird decision to make for a Joshua
Williamson because when it came to James
Jesse who named himself after the
reverse of Jesse James when it came to
his character originally he was a bad
guy he would just use like tricks and
things like that you know what to
deceive heroes and implement schemes and
so on and so forth but his character
over the course of I mean Hellfire guy I
spent like 40 or 50 years uh he had that
like this huge turn around and basically
became like a good guy and
ended up dying but then to bring him
back and presumably you know seemingly
play the role of a villain it is kind of
a return to familiarity insofar as he's
going back to his roots and becoming a
bad guy but we don't really know what
all happened here I mean if I'm a
betting man based on what we've seen in
Doomsday Clock one with dr. Manhattan
plucking comedian out of time and
bringing him to the DC Universe so that
he just never died at the end of
Watchmen with dr. Manhattan moving the
lantern just out of reach so that Alan
Scott ends up dying instead of becoming
the original Green Lantern within making
like these small adjustments here and
there this may yet be another one where
he basically plucked the original tricks
are out of Apocalypse so he wouldn't be
killed and so he's still on earth and
maybe maybe even went as far back as to
adjust and so he never became a good guy
in the first place we don't really know
but but still is it's kind of cool and
it's pretty intriguing but without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys are
the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]